i didn't even know that uh but
um for me i guess it was more special
um i'm thinking more about either than
january 2010 when i was officially
number one for the first time or
in i think it was october uh
2008 when i was unofficially number one
for for the first time so
um but yeah it's it's been a long time
what would you say has been the
highlight
within those ten years um
yeah i think the highlight still for me
has been
first first half of 2019 where
everything
sort of sort of clicked and i had
also my joint highest rating of all time
so yeah
i would say that was the highlight have
you ever felt like big pressure or even
conservative scared about losing the
number one spot
oh for sure there have been a lot of
games or even
just moves that i could have lost
the number one spot for instance in the
match against carrano there were
a number of games where i was struggling
so
the fact that it's been so long
there's obviously some some luck
involved there as well
10 years consecutive world number one
how long do you tend to keep it
um i don't have any particular plans but
i'm
at least happy that the gap
is pretty uh pretty wide again now after
karana lost a few points in romania so
for the moment it's not a big concern
ten more years
um unlikely but we'll see